especially men that's what a midlife
crisis I think is for dudes is they
realize that they've made a bunch of bad
choice or choice they don't like and
they're stuck and they don't know how to
get out but they won't ask themselves a
hard question they won't look at the
things that they haven't done their
responsibilities to haven't taken in
their life they won't make any hard
decisions and so they're stuck dude it
sucks man when you get there but the
only way to avoid that is to constantly
look at yourself and do your work and
you're by work I mean emotional work am
I being the best person I can am I being
honest with myself if you're constantly
honestly asking yourself these questions
you can't help but grow you're gonna
grow that's just how it works and then
you change and then you know you become
hopefully a better and better a better
version of yourself not always the same
I'm never gonna be as cool cool as I was
when I was 29 right in certain ways but
like I'm Way better in almost every
other way
I'm joined by Tucker max Tucker look at
the show
Thank You program me pleasure to have
your man I was saying earlier I posted
out that I was gonna have you on the
show and my DMS have just been on fire
all day originally were just gonna talk
about scribe media and we're gonna go
into the nuances of book write in and
stuff like that we're gonna get into
that but I think there's some other bits
that I'd love to get into first so to
kind of set the scene for people who
might not fully know your backstory
how do you get to where you are now head
of scribe media best-selling author
books of how did you get there right so
it's a long back source all hit the
highlights and then you can kind of dive
into wherever you want
let me so let's see how went to
undergrad University of Chicago Law
School at Duke and then got fired from
being a lawyer in three weeks my dad
fired me from the family business in six
months then didn't really know what to
do
found my way in to write I was writing
emails to my friends that they thought
were hilarious
and through a long series of sort of
stuff I ended up putting my stuff up on
a website my stories they blew up I've
got a ton of attention you know MTV
girls sued me it was all the sort of
normal controversy and then um so ended
up writing a book became I hope they
serve beer in hell which the New York
Times that invented a literary genre
called flat tire and it's sold a billion
and a half copies now or more worldwide
translated into whatever it is 30 or 40
languages something and then wrote two
more books well first there was a movie
made about that book about my life and
then the two more books [ __ ]
finished first and Larry and Sue sorry
in sloppy seconds three more books those
are all told of sold I don't know three
and a half four million ish and then did
a few other things the big thing was
start scribe like I said a bunch people
ask me how do I write and publish a book
and so I started a company that helps
people do that
and it's five years later and you know
we did David Goggins book which is huge
at Tiffany Haddish and a bunch of others
and so here we are
man what a story I love how you said all
of the normal sort of controversy
getting sued by ex-girlfriends and stuff
on a on a consistent basis that's funny
yet so one of the things that I really
wanted to delve into with you because I
think that you've got quite unique
insight on this because you've been so
transparent in that journey from going
and being you know a classic party boy
right the UK's got a big drinking
culture a big party culture my job I
fill nightclubs I've run nightclubs for
thirteen years that's what I do bread
and butter right so I've seen like a
million drug people ish just over a
million drug people so I know I know
what it looks like and so does everyone
that's listening um well I'm really
interested in finding out is what
happens when we go from as men young men
we go from being that guy who is living
quite viscerally party lifestyle there's
a point where it's for some people
gradual for some people sudden but
there's a point where you stop being
that and you start to be a simulacrum of
the guy that your dad is or was or you
know it's dad to be you get me like
there's not many dads that I know even
you know I've got some friends that are
pretty loose I don't know many of the
dads that are out on the lash in the
same way that 22 year olds out on the
lodge yeah and they're bad dads yeah
you're right so what was that process
like for you because obviously you were
so transparent such a big partier all of
these sort of very well publicized
experiences and now you a dad to you two
wonderful kids three yeah man
congratulations how are you up to
it's so funny dude you're definitely
English because there is no American
podcaster that would ever use the word
stimulator oh I know what that means
thank God I have like advanced degrees
because most Americans the [ __ ] is he
talking about what is this sorry
all right so yeah you know what's funny
to Manuel my books came out like
they blew up in America and all this
controversy or whatever and all the
English people were like well one of the
Americans up in arms about everyone does
this this dude just got drunk and throw
up and act like an idiot like no the
British were like they didn't thought it
was funny and some dude but they were
like you guys America is a whole
different culture with that stuff man
like my books in England with it like
they did they did okay because there was
no element of naughtiness @cd missed it
you know but anyway so how did I become
a dad so it's funny at least in America
I'm not sure England in America the the
stereotype is the bad boy gets converted
by his love for the right woman right
that's always how it works and but
that's never how it that's always Sarah
time it's never how it actually works in
America if you're like a you know like
the bad boy is a younger guy you kind of
there's two paths there's two archetypes
you can take you can keep going right
and like play that up like I could have
played yeah listen I could have I'm 44
now I could be the 44 year old guy
traveling the world still banging young
girls and whatever like I know those
guys they usually go on own bars or or
promote nightclubs a lot of them or they
you know they get into that lifestyle or
things that are similar entertainment
business whatever or you you basically
like reformed right those are the kind
of archetypes but neither of those are
what I didn't want to be the old creepy
dude like that was unappealing to me but
I wasn't gonna reform like in terms of
like oh what I did was bad now I have to
be good that was [ __ ] but what I did
do which is like not
it's an archetype but it's not the way
it plays out in America is I did my work
right so the question is always not why
do young people go out and drink and
have fun but why did some young people
especially and I was definitely one of
them go to ridiculous extremes with it
right at least what I did in America was
extreme
might not be Franklin but for America
was and so it's always a question of
like why right and then I had to really
I made all this money I did those stuff
I basically got to the point where like
everything in my life was perfect uh you
know as good as it could be I was in
amazing shape I had money I was rich I
was famous I girls and I said I was way
way better off than when I was a poor
and anonymous right and broken starving
and whatever but like I still wasn't
that happy right now wasn't that content
and so then I had to ask myself some
point you realize well the problems me
right so what sort of Ages you remember
huh what sort of age was this 34 or 35
was right after the movie right and so
eat so you have to make that decision do
you realize the problem is you or not
right and then most people don't man
most people think know that everything
is the problems always outside of me so
they spend the rest of their lives
chasing money or success or women or
drugs or whatever it is they use to run
from their emotions I don't mean that
judgmentally it's just because God knows
I was doing it for a long time but like
or they say they turn inwards and say
all right I'm gonna fix my [ __ ] right
and I started that about 3035 really in
earnest and man that's been a hard road
dude like because it is it's funny it's
like I forget the Buddha the Buddha it's
like you know it's something about like
it's not hard to conquer an army it's
hard to conquer yourself right and I
thought when I was like 24 a time like
the Buddha didn't always talking about
it doesn't do with a ball and roll shut
up man
now my god to do with wives there's a
reason people listening for 5,000 years
cuz
turning inwards and dealing with your
own [ __ ] was really hard and so for me
it started with just high level I
started with their talk therapy like
psychoanalysis and that worked for like
four years for me really well
I gave me a good map of my mind and my
emotions but I didn't really feel a lot
like it didn't it kind of I understood
what's going on sort of like having a
map of London and walking around the
streets of one totally different things
right and so that's what it gave me a
map and then um I started working with a
shaman for a while like an energy healer
not because I thought it would be a good
idea this woman just like I thought that
was nonsense and this woman did some
[ __ ] with me once they're like my wife
is like why are you so different today
I'm like what do you mean she's saying
no no no you're way better and I hadn't
told her oh it sounds like crap not
gonna work with this [ __ ] yeah this
proofs in the pudding right very
frustrating for me and so we're for
about a year and that was fine it worked
well didn't stop working and then I did
a few other things here and there
nothing really worked that well I'm and
I tried everything else yoga whatever
all those other things pill try didn't
work for me and then the last 18 months
man I've made more progress and I
probably made the other nine years
combined and that's with plant medicines
so like therapeutic indie you know a
psychotherapy mdma-assisted
psychotherapy you know and psilocybin
assisted and that kind of stuff has just
man and it's like it's like a startup
where you see like slow growth and also
may hit the rocket ship I've hit the
rocket ship I think I still haven't
really gotten into the serious stuff
it's just gone way better blast 18
months for me have been amazing dude the
growth you know and so how do I get to
be where I dad to answer that question
first I had did it I did decide I wanted
I knew I wanted a family and then I was
like trying to date girls and then like
they all sucked and that my analyst was
like this associate analyst she's like
well are you who's the type of woman you
want to meet and marry and so I like
listed this woman and she's like like it
was like this amazing avatar of woman
and she's like okay with that girl want
to date you and I'm like of course she
would I'm rich
I'm also right it seems like hold on
sucker
you may be rich and famous but you're
also sleeping with like two girls a week
and bobble well why is that girl gonna
date you why is she gonna be one of many
why and I was like tried to go through
that whole process I had to get ready to
meet my wife that was that was the big
thing and in like that it wasn't most
people just fall into this man and for
me it was a conscious evolution with a
lot of fits and starts and musics along
the way does that answer your question
absolutely man I got a million doorways
opened so I think we got lots to delve
into firstly yeah I totally I totally
get what you mean
I'm currently rereading mark Manson's
models and he talks he talks a lot about
that right about that compatibility like
where are you finding the women that you
that you want today where are you going
like if you want someone that's
intellectual like going out to the club
five nights a week might not be yeah for
sure and you're actually flipping that
on its head you're like am I the sort of
person that the sort of girl I want to
date would want to date certainly one
who thinks guys never even think that
question but they just prefer a man
think of it I think that most men
because of the way that dating and
romance is popularized I think that most
men presumed that their job is to kind
of be there it's like if I'm here and
I'm not fat and my my shirts not got
enough stuff on it and like the girl
turns up like kind of you know there's
no real I don't know it just I don't
think there's a narrative that men have
to follow that's that's too good for
that but I mentioned before we started
I've kind of been immersed in tokamaks
over the last weekend I've been
traveling a lot
consuming a lot of stuff that you've
bought out recently one of the things
that struck me is that you're very very
prepared to do introspective work and
uncover quite ugly truths about yourself
which is something that over the last
four years I've taken an almost
cathartic pleasure in doing for myself
I've really strangely enjoyed it that
challenge and you enjoyed I enjoyed the
results of it I am being done the
process is never like oh let's tear the
[ __ ] visor off and look at that hard
fierce truth that's awful and no one
wants know I'm not like oh yeah yeah
yeah the process is uncomfortable I
think my curiosity and my desire to kind
of find out why about me I think is
pretty strong um so talk to us about
about sort of being able to see
transparencies right because you would
this guy you had one kind of persona
even if that was you living your truth
and I think that you were yeah so as
that truth starts to change there'll be
parts of you that I want to cling on to
the old you and you know girls that are
listening guys who maybe can't quite
resonate with the young party guy will
still know this right you have these
epochs of your life you have these
little sections you're going through and
you've got a how do you stop letting go
or the last one you're the guy the party
guy
now you're the party the guy who used to
be the party guy now you're the writer
now you're the you know I mean how do
you see so it's hard man so the metaphor
the question are it's funny man like I
get this all the time I'm 44 with three
kids and a very mature business like we
we did eight figures in revenue last
year I'm not even a CEO like I heard a
bollard of running my company right and
so yeah I live in a huge house [ __ ]
pool or a wine cellar an insured wine
cellar like all this sources and I still
get the dudes who like message me on
Instagram or whatever is like what the
[ __ ] man like when we
get more stories and I'm like my
response is always some version of the
same you played with toys you played
with dolls when you were 10 do you still
play with him now that you're 25 and
they're always like it doesn't even
occur to them that if they think about
it obviously but doesn't occur to them
that like life has phases and life has
seasons and that certain things make a
lot of sense at a certain season and
make no sense than any other season
right and especially with someone who's
like celebrity or noteworthy right
because what happens people don't
realize like you have like a okay at you
see this with athletes all the time
people have a very an emotionally
intense relationship with an athlete in
one stage of their life like their let's
say I don't know whatever 26 - like 33
they're like huge and all Lionel Messi
or Michael Jordan or LeBron James like
Pisa and so like it doesn't matter how
like like for me that was Michael Jordan
when I was a young kid right Michael
Jordan was the guy and now Michaels like
you know his sixties or whatever he's
like old disgusting of fat and he's an
[ __ ] his whole life but now you're
really no and but still like people like
if he was a god to you when you were 15
then like he's always a guy and you like
approach him that way right you look at
him like and it's very frustrating
because you can't people don't look at
you like a person you're like an object
right and and so that's why a lot of
those people get stuck is because they
first up that they were at their peak
them they're never gonna get bigger
right in terms of whatever success at
basketball let's just say with Jordan
he's never gonna be bigger a basketball
than he was in the late night it's just
not possible right and and then he has
people around him who always look at him
that way and so he stuck with it right
and that almost happened to me of course
I was nowhere near as big as Jordan but
like and I you could you could make that
happen and I'm not talking about just
celebrities in anything you could just
be you know a good I don't know big in
your little social circle whatever
and this say it's the same dynamic you
you know how I always phrase it you can
tell a man's peak year in his life
because his wardrobe freezes they're
like my grandfather I could tell what
his peak year was after he died me
krita's closet because he didn't buy
anything else from anything past that
period he just froze his wardrobe right
there and he didn't change you think
that's a symbolic he's trying to saw a
hold on to that well beyond that they
hold on to the car the clothes whatever
most right and that was just something
that like I I was never like I tried for
a little while the hold on but I'm like
what am i doing man I'm like this isn't
life this doesn't make sense
and it's not about aging gracefully it's
about growing and evolving and becoming
the best version of who you are now and
that's why I like I don't understand
these people were like man dude I love
being older man like everything is
better except like physical stuff
basically like I have more money I have
more wisdom
I have a better friends I'm more
emotionally together in every single
everything's better in my life except
like you know I can't deadlift as much
anymore I'm a shitty athlete now my
knees hurt a little my right you know
like I used to be able to have sex
whatever five nights or five times a
night now like man 3 is like not easy
for me right and like so yeah but like
if you and that's why especially men
that's what a midlife crisis I think is
for dudes is they realize that they've
they've made a bunch of bad choices or
choices they don't like and they're
stuck and they don't know how to get out
but they won't do what you talked about
doing before they won't look it they
won't ask themselves a hard question
they won't look at the things that they
haven't done their responsibility to
haven't taken in their life they won't
make any hard decisions and so they're
stuck right and like that's just yeah
dude it sucks man when you get there but
the only way to avoid that is to
constantly
not reinvent you don't have to reinvent
man you have to constantly look at
yourself and and do your work and your
by work I mean emotional work am i being
the best person I can am I being honest
with myself taking responsibility for
myself am i doing these things and if
you're constantly honestly asking
yourself these questions you can't help
but grow you're gonna grow that's just
how it works and then you change and
then you know you become whatever I'll
hopefully a better and better a better
version of yourself not always the same
though it's not like there's thing I'm
never gonna be as cold cool as I was
when I was 29 right in certain ways but
like I'm Way better than almost every
other way I think you know what's
interesting about that is people will
find both men and women they will find
some form of success in quotation marks
some form of effectiveness within one
particular domain and then they just
continue to double down double down
double down double down and I don't know
who the quotes from you might be able to
tell me who this is but the goal is not
to win the game the goal is to keep on
playing yeah I think that's from a book
called finit in infinite games I forget
the author simon Sinek design mistake on
that yes a good friend of mine yes
Simon's book about infinite games he got
there's a book called infinite and
infinite games which is like where he
got that a lot of that idea okay but
it's not cynic he gets credit for too
much other [ __ ] don't give him some
that's the problem isn't it it's a
people are kind of like that James out
which is the same and so yeah people
have a little bit success continue to
double down on that stick to this
particular thing but it's not about that
it's about moving on to what is next and
you're right as well you've touched on
the fact that your social circle
reinforces that right even your your fan
base they're not your social circle but
they're like you're the this guy you're
the party guy you're the drunk guy
you're the girls sleeping with girls guy
you're the self development guy you're
the writer guy and as you perhaps want
to evolve especially if you have a
being they don't want you to know
because their relationship with you is
based on its objectification you are
something you nailed it you are
something to them you are not a person
to them at all like I kept talking about
this and fame forever you are not a
person to them at all yeah I mean like
it's not that like it's big boy it all
boils down to to me twelfth Michael
Jordan's not a person he's an idealized
basketball God he's not a human he's not
a man right because a man is flawed and
complex and vulnerable and all the own
all these things right Michael Jordan's
none of those things I mean he is a guy
did this is the purpose of myth and gods
for humans and because we don't believe
in God anymore that's just been replaced
by celebrities right and so that's why
they get these idealized should people
would use to treat celebrities like this
IVA treating them well in high status is
a different thing than this idealized
worship yeah I couldn't agree more
I'll tell you what I do I know that you
touch on CrossFit as well right you've
done a little bit cross for any time so
you'll understand this because course
it's such a fast changing sport you can
tell who how long they've someone's been
doing Crossfit
by who their favorite athlete is that
all you're a rich Froning guy or you're
a jason khalipa or you're a Matt Fraser
guy like gin I mean and it's such a
fast-moving sport it's kind of so I've
got a million doors always open but one
of the things I really want to get get
into is you're quite a cerebral person
from what I can tell you liked to be
able to rationalize you can rationalize
you're sufficiently clever to be able to
do that a lot of the time when we think
that we're doing the work you've spoken
about this right do the work uncover
your hidden biases what are the motives
that are guiding your life what are the
things that you need to work on what the
things that you need to do but if you
are sufficiently cerebral or you can
tell yourself good enough stories a lot
of the time you can come up with
something which is a proxy for the truth
this is this isn't actually doing the
work but it's close enough for me to
feel like I'm satisfied in doing the
work it's like McDonald's versus food
right it's like it fills you up but it's
kind of not nutritious yeah how do we
talk about that we'll do that I mean
that's that's the trap right I
I forget the quote it was somebody like
it was somebody like the Buddha or
someone one of his many many disciples
who said that the cleverest trick of the
ego is to bend spirituality to its
wishes right and so like you see this in
people who I'll give you a really good
example so for years there was a civic
person I'm thinking about but a couple
people but really one who's famous I'm
gonna say his name because he's still a
friend of mine I have said this to his
face so but I just don't want to like
you know put my private conversations
with in public but like he would not
shut the [ __ ] up about ayahuasca like
just every conversation I had with this
dude ayahuasca this and ayahuasca that
ayahuasca you gotta do ayahuasca and
like I don't mind someone like oh yeah
you know I I don't think it's wise to
talk about psychedelics that way you
shouldn't recommend their do people talk
about your experience and let them come
to there on their own but like we knew
each other well enough where it was fine
but like his life was [ __ ] up man like
dude your life is a mess and if you're
telling me to do this it makes me not
want to do it and so like I didn't do it
for a long time because like like i
associated it with him in his mess right
and so so like it to bring it back to
your question um it's cold in what I
realized like once I got deeper into
that realm and I got to the real
practice like he was new to it I got to
the real practitioners who've been doing
it 10 or 20 years and who were serious
on medicine and like yeah be a plant
medicine and like ayahuasca shamans and
other shamans they have a name for what
he what he was doing they call it
spiritual bypass right and basically
it's the people who use these medicines
to get the experience a very spin to
feel spiritual and to feel like they had
something happen but not do any of the
actual underlying thought what you were
talking about before the really hard
emotional work be seeing your shadow
right realizing things you've done
taking accountability for your actions
all owning your [ __ ] right and so like
that's what I was like Oh once that got
explained to me I'm like okay my
problems not with him it's with how he's
acting and I I could actually do this
right it's not I get it
so um dude that's one of the hardest
things man I can't tell you how this and
the worst part is the smarter you are
that like your defenses are as smart as
you right
and so like oh dude there's a
never-ending wall between you and you're
smarter brain yeah yeah well your ego is
designed to keep you alive right to keep
you safe and the main tool it has to
keep you alive
his stasis it wants to keep you the same
because if you're alive now right doing
what you're doing
changing is a risk of death yeah yeah
it's so like it doesn't want you to
change not because it's against you it's
just like imagine like you know like the
super conservative hyper risk-averse mom
that's your ego right and so like what
you have to do what I've had to do is um
learn to get in a diet I have to see it
first understand oh [ __ ] my brain is
tricking me
my ego the part that my part of ego part
of my brain is tricking me to stop me
from growing and changing right and then
I get a dialogue and it's like okay hold
on like you have to realize there's
different parts of your brain that have
different agendas and it's actually
great like they all work in balance the
movie um inside out from Pixar is an
amazing example of this like have you
seen that movie no I it's like you big
Pixar's a kids movie it's an amazing
movie because it shows you how like
sadness happy joy anger like these are
all discussed your core emotions all
have very important purposes and work
together right and then it again a
balance that I get messed up but like
it's
it's really really really really hard to
do that man to really understand there
is a part of me trying to keep you the
same and it's a good valuable part I
just need to not listen to it all the
time because if I want to grow I've got
to change right yeah then I've got to
take that risk dude that took me I don't
know how long it took me
III did a session that was with
obviously a very experienced guy with a
specific type of medicine that I kind of
created an ego death like when your ego
really does die and you and dude it was
crazy man as I was going into this is
like a serious serious one
it's like Adele and um I heard myself I
thought I was thinking they tricked you
this is your new reality you're gonna
get stuck here you're gonna die right I
thought I was thinking that exactly what
you want just as you're entering a trip
right and a big one and so like of
course I'm like freaked out whatever but
at that point I'm pretty experienced I
was with people I knew where and
entrusted and they saved Marlon so like
I was able to kind of surrender and let
go it wasn't until a few days later I
was like hold on a minute that was my
[ __ ] you know dying that was like oh
my god that's when I realized like the
trick the ego plays on you is it
convinces it convinces you that it is
you that you and your ego or the same
thing and they are not it's a part of
you it's an important part of you it can
just be destructive you listen too much
that's what the Buddhists mean when they
say you are the observer not the speaker
right is they're saying the real the
true self is the self that sees and
observes and experiences and the ego and
all these other parts of you are
different parts of your brain that like
are part of you but not you and I do I'm
still trying to figure this out now like
it's like I'm not like some you know son
monk that's been doing this for 40 years
right like I'm 18 months in but it all
made sense I mean soon as I as soon as I
understood that then then I started like
really kind of essentially talking to
myself and I did like a crane
person sort of but in a different way
and realizing okay I'm afraid of that or
I'm I'm I'm telling myself I don't want
to do that it's like hold on why am i
doing that because you know like what's
a good example my mom right I don't have
a good relationship with my mom I just
kind of like that all came to a head
like and so long story short I didn't
talk to her in 12 years and so I
realized I needed to reach out to her
and I didn't want to and so I had this
whole sort of like battle with myself
right and I realized the egos like no
don't reach out to her enough that she
was wrong to all these things these are
good arguments for the hold on you're
trying to keep me the same I get it
thank you for protecting me I'm gonna
reach out and then like we didn't meet
up but because of the dynamics around I
was able to just let that go I had all
this [ __ ] resentment and anger and
literally I was able to let all that go
because I didn't listen to my ego there
this make sense I'm sorry man
absolutely well it sounds like recently
you made a graph for the people that
were listening you talked about a graph
you can imagine one that's going up
exponentially it's getting more and more
as time goes on and the increases are
getting greater as well when you talked
about your progress and you were
highlighting the fact that the plant
medicines really kind of supercharged
that over the last 19 months
one thing that I'm fascinated by is this
period we're talking about for men and I
can't speak for women but it might
happen for girls as well but for men you
know maybe between mid to late twenties
to hopefully mid 30s where something
happens they start to realize like I
need to kind of let go of that last that
past version of myself right do you
think that you can make you can have
these insights inning and have that
conversation with the ego without doing
some of the work first you know for
instance can I just dive into plant
medicine is it just gonna enlighten me
or could you have could you be where you
are now without having been nine years
of psychotherapy and it's hard to say
man it really is it depends on the
person dude you're not so you could all
right so I know a girl who is totally in
touch with her emotions and like doesn't
take any of this stuff and she's fine
and people like Michael singer
you know who wrote the untethered soul
like you know a huge book that dude just
sat in a [ __ ] swamp and meditated two
hours a day right and got there and so
no no you do not need plant medicines to
get there I do not think you do but are
they really helpful for a lot of people
yes were they at this point for me and
all the trauma that I've been through
were they basically a necessity for me
yeah I think um maybe assessee maybe I
don't know they worked and and they were
amazing for me I think it was
opportunity for things using
psychedelics and plant medicines to heal
and using them to let's call it um
expand your mind and reach higher levels
of consciousness they're very related
but they're not the exact same thing I
have been mainly focused on using
psychedelics and plant medicines to heal
trauma and to connect with myself better
now by default I've had some
consciousness raising and seeing some
crazy stuff and whatever but like that's
not been my focus and a lot of people
who start with psychedelics I think
start there like let's do five mao DNT
and see what happens right and it's like
look you can start there but that's like
learning to swim in the middle of the
Pacific like I guess you could do it but
probably what would you recommend man
yeah like that's why I start with the
MDMA cuz it's so safe it's so gentle
it's so effective on on trauma and like
and it's like it's a it's like learning
to swim in the kiddie pool you know so
yeah man like if you want it if you
don't want to be stuck if you're afraid
of being stuck it's very very simple
it's very simple to understand
the reason you're stuck is because
you're holding on trying to hold on to
something that you can't hold on
then diss understand you gotta let go
and the only thing you can do is ride
the waves not hold on the thing that is
unwhole double and that search
exaggerated metaphor I come Maggie
trying to like say alright this awesome
wave that I'm on I'm just gonna stay on
this way and you look at them like are
you [ __ ] it's gonna hit the beach
it's not you can't ride away forever
because waves aren't forever but yeah
and life is the same way it really is
the exact same way so whatever phase
you're in and now I'm not saying don't
bail on the way even say you have to if
you got a good wave and you're on it
right it right and for as long as you
can but when it's over and let it go
same thing with whatever phase of life
you're in
I get it man are you totally right I
think what's interesting when we start
to strip away persona right we're
looking at who we are
hang on I'm now attached to something
that I was but I no longer am I need to
update my software I'm now about to be a
dad I'm becoming a dad I want to get a
girlfriend who could become my wife all
of these things the frustrating thing
that I've found over the last four years
is it's like pass the parcel like you
strip away some of the the wrapping
paper and then underneath the wrapping
paper there's some more wrapping paper
and you just keep on going in you're
like [ __ ] I thought like you keep on
tearing it off and you know this this
got to be the last one this has to be
the like below this it's gonna be the
last one and then you just keep on going
keep on going keep on going it's just
all wrapping paper I wonder if that's
the game yeah realizing there's nothing
there yeah that's I mean that's what not
just the Buddhists but almost any
tradition will tell you like at the end
of the day that look it's funny the last
18 months I've done so much reading into
a lot of people I hadn't really paid a
close attention to before people like
Rumi Jesus I knew a lot of Buddhism but
like really kind of diving in to
different different angles um and what's
funny is they all say the same thing
like they really say the exact same
thing Buddha said everything you
everything you need everything you
require you having jesus said the
kingdom of heaven is with him Rumi said
all the stars in the galaxy all the
stars in the sky are nothing compared to
the the journey inward or something like
that
they all said the exact all the great
avatars said the exact same thing that
everything you need you have inside it's
just a matter of going inward doing that
work you know that's it
that's all it is man like it it's I feel
like an if anyone's listening to this
and think this dude's an idiot or a
crazy person I get it because two years
ago I would have said the same thing
with some of it but it's like once you
get it it makes total sense and and
now it's like it's funny to man because
like we were pretty successful two years
ago but it might like the success and
stuff I'm doing it's just going up up up
up and it's like it's gone up an almost
direct proportion to how much I've let
go of not working right like I'm here
doing a podcast I do I not working but
trying holding on to I've got to have
this or I've got to have that or I'm
trying to work it straight batter this
is the thing I need to succeed and
understanding that I have it you know
it's all right here and that whether I
succeed or fail is essentially a spot
the story I tell myself and a feeling I
have and then I actually get to control
that and I get to decide that
it sounds so trite from the outside man
but once you get it it just clicks how
do you marry that very holistic view
with failures and success in life with
the fact that you need to get up and do
the grind I don't think you have to run
if you're running you're doing it wrong
hustle because by definition a grind is
awful it's okay it's seriously like but
you know what my days are man oh yeah my
Monday sometimes are a little bit of a
grind because they're had a lot of calls
a lot of things like this and some of
them I like like this conversation is
pretty cool not all of them so like
there's always I have not fully here but
my life now is 80-ish 80% things that I
love doing things that energize me like
if you want a rubric
manage your energy right the things that
energize you do those the things that
don't energize you either don't do or if
you have to do them pay someone to do
them who is energized by them like the
idea that I would have to like put
numbers in a spreadsheet they put a
bullet in my brain but the two
accountants at my company love it they
just lie it's like their thing right so
we hired people that you know they do
that and like we trade and it's great
you know they don't like talking to
people I'm real good at that that sucks
yes so we but we both spend our days
doing things that energize us right and
I think most people don't do that they
load their brain with shoulds I should
do that shoulds in halves have to do
this should do that
it's a [ __ ] story in your head there
I've yet to meet a person who's like
really truly has a sugar half story that
can't be broken down and I know there's
a million people is that although mine's
different yeah ain't [ __ ] different
man I had all those things and I'm a
better arguer than you yeah we get back
to the brain being able to convince us
of pretty much anything right I recently
had come out rather con on and he was
he's got this little he's good guy man
had he's got the three steps of how he
sees life life happens to me life
happens for me life happens through me
right and it's that it ties into a
victim mentality it ties into leaning
into discomfort which is one of my
favorite sayings which talks about lean
into discomfort as if you invited it
through the door you know it's the this
this is something that's here it's here
for growth it and um you know it's all
tied together I don't know how I don't
know how it all fits together but it is
yeah I mean I feel like I'm on the cusp
of real I feel like I've kind of got it
but not well enough to explain it's
anybody right but here's the thing with
this man is I'll tell you the things
that I have like I got it so you can't
really truly explain you can you can use
words but the gap between understanding
and words is big and so like it's sort
of like imagine okay so this is one you
can get no one would think that watching
you can learn about sex from watching
porn you get some information from it
right but the gap between having sex and
watching porn is huge and you really
believe it know how big the gap is to
start having sex right oh wow like
everything I mean everything the
experience that I'm good at is how
different it is everything right is
different you can understand how they're
related but they're really totally
different same thing is true about
trying to talk about enlightenment right
the words don't work you know and like
we use words because that's how we
communicate words and symbols and
pictures but what we you and I are
talking about right now is experiential
you must walk the path food this is the
best Buddhist quote it is not enough to
read the words of Buddha you must walk
his path right you have got to do this
work to understand it and you can use
other people's experiences and examples
and words as guides that's really
helpful but it is low substitute which
is this is the problem with Christianity
is that basically from the Catholic
Church onward the church has tried to
replace Jesus's experience they try to
take his experience and make people
substitute a acted out version of his
experience for their experience right
that's the problem with Christianity is
that it's not you don't
period the the the the feeling you act
out jesus's you know that's communion
right all that sort of [ __ ] whereas the
Buddhists will tell you know know you've
got to actually do the work
same with Islam you don't actually
experience it it's Muhammad's words
right
I think that's [ __ ] I think that was
the really the big thing that
psychedelics showed me and that the path
is like oh I have to experience this
like that's the irony is I was totally
atheist before and now I'm Way more
about formal religious but like way more
like oh I totally good Jesus now 100%
accepting us total reality no because
like now I felt that I've experienced it
like I got none of that secret through
any sort of formal religion but now I
understand what skald an ecstatic
experience now I totally get it I know
what he's I know what he meant when he
said the kingdom of heaven is with him
there was no word you could have
explained to me then I did you know like
a massive dose of mushrooms and a
therapeutic setting or like oh [ __ ] this
is what he means yeah it's interesting
that you say that your experiences with
psychedelics have caused you to become
slightly more spiritual and religiously
minded or at least religiously accepting
one of the co-hosts of the show Yousef
was Muslim until around about 2223 and
then a psychedelic trip caused him to
recant religion overnight which because
all it is think of it it's just someone
standing between you and eggs and they
in the experience telling you you have
to rely on me to tell you what the
experience is the interpreter that's
trying to make it I really appreciate
what you what you said is well about the
how words can't really describe the
sensation especially for me someone who
prides himself on being precise with his
speech I try and be I try and articulate
right I try and be lucid I try and do
these things but they're just proxies
for the notion that we have they're just
a real they this thing is for
experiences
I'm trying I'm trying to get it out and
the words even words themselves read
1984 write read 1984 and that tells you
all that you need to know about how
language is related to the thoughts that
we have in our brains if you remove if
you does if you don't have the words the
thoughts essentially don't they never
get communicated they don't exist they
don't exist outside of ephemeral
nebulous cloudy little notions and I had
their experiences what they are there
are no that's can't communion you you
mentioned about the two paths to do with
psychedelic therapy one one being
consciousness-raising one being more
therapeutic um what is it that is making
that determination is it intention going
in is it satin setting is it dosage is
it a combination it's a lot of those
things man
it really is but so when I say
therapeutic I mean like yeah like
basically figuring out what your trauma
is and then or you're stuck emotions
call it because all really trauma is is
unfelt emotion unfilled feelings and so
it's essentially making it easier for
you to feel that so that you can then
let it go right and and psychedelics
make that with the right guidance and
the right intention the right set and
setting the right psychedelics it's not
all are good at that but but the ones
that are good at that are a [ __ ]
magical dude like MDMA is amazing and it
lower dose mushrooms or pretend to be
pretty good at it
LSD can be in certain areas there's
others like I mean I'm not the expert on
that side I know it pretty well but I'm
not the dude you would call to be the
expert but like I if you do the mind
expansion and consciousness expansion
stuff without the trauma work beforehand
it's doable but you're it's sort of like
um getting a really nice car and taking
it for a fast drive with the windshield
like durty you know like it makes it a
lot harder it can be first off that's
how you can get really dark stuff like
that's what a quote bad trip is is you
take a bunch of
and it's nellis you didn't do anything
to you it brought up a lot of stuff you
have in you and you aren't ready or
willing to deal with it that's what a
bad trip is there's a few exceptions
that are very rare or whatever with but
but for most people that's what a bad
trip is and so like that's why for most
people it's you want to do your work
first it's like it's sort of like you
know um the way I think about it just
for shorthand is like I gotta clean my
house before I try and go talk to God
right
and so it's like I'm not gonna go talk
to God with a dirty house and so I gotta
get my house at least in order doesn't
have to be perfect but I gotta get
everything put away I gotta get all all
cleaned once my house is in order then I
can go take my meeting you know it seems
like to me MDMA is it's been a number of
clinical trials now for it being used
for PTSD therapy being used for a lot of
different a lot of different things and
for me my experience I've never taken
MDMA in my life without being drunk in a
club that's it like a you know I mean
it's not a therapeutic drug to me it
doesn't even speak of psychedelic in a
psychedelic
it's not even in that class it's a
totally different molecular compound yep
um it's not at all but dude when you
take it to say I know a lot of people
who used to do like a gram of India may
a weekend or crazy stuff like that
writing a lot and then they you know
they they went to that phase and now
they're out and they do it therapeutic
Lee and it's like feel like oh my god I
had no idea like totally totally
different experience that's fascinating
that is really really fascinating I
really hope that he gets rolled out more
I think it's got a lot of it'll be legal
in probably in America it's actually
there's a few places where you can do it
compassionate care licenses those
clinics are being opened this year it'll
be widely legal in 2021 or 2022 probably
it's already in stage three clinical
trials like the therapeutic use
prescription and although he okay um you
mentioned so one of the flags in the
ground of your life of the transition
from old
took her to mute rocket was when you
said that you're kind of giving up frat
ire which was this particular type of
writing the done and since then am i
right in thinking the only thing you've
brought out is this scribe method is
that right no I wrote a book with Jeff
Miller called what women want which is
my guide for guys about how to deal with
women kind of understand women how to
deal with women I talked to him I'm
attracted to him all that sort stuff
it's the best book on that subject by
far in the marketplace we did a pretty
poor job positioning it and and
marketing that book is like the the best
example ever that product doesn't beat
marketing all the time right like
there's all these idiots that have all
this dumb [ __ ] stuff out there that they
market the hell out of and like we
didn't want to approach it that way and
like so we ended up like we wrote the
best book it's by far the best info like
the dudes who read it a lot do that we
get I can email every week from I guys I
oh my god I smell this money always
changes and it was all yeah it has
changed my life and whatever the problem
with the book man is that we don't play
be it's not your fault game we don't
blame women for problem we don't play up
to the most toxic emotions and dudes and
so like it's it's it's a lot harder to
sell personal responsibility and
accountability it's a lot harder to sell
hard like real hard work and it's hard
to sell facing your problems and things
like that which is what we we do in
there but what's funny is like I told
news I'm like listen you want to have
the life I have go do this book
that's it man you want to be married to
a an incredible amazing woman who's hot
have a bunch of kids with her
have a whole bunch of money you know
whatever whatever however I'm not the
details my life don't matter right
because I couldn't even give [ __ ] about
mine whatever success looks like by the
metric you've made this looks like to
you yeah it's here you just have to do
the work it's not complicated it's just
difficult isn't it fascinating that you
what you wrote a book that was
positioned to virtuously for it to come
eyes on its own on its own success yeah
that's really interesting so the guys
there's a video going around Twitter
today from you know the guys from 21
convention you know that is yes yeah
yeah so the dude behind that forgot his
name which kind of says it all the dude
behind the 21 convention thing was on a
British talk show this morning with
Piers Morgan you'll know who he is
Morgan his peers and it doesn't really
pull his punches and him and him and
this female co-host just tear this guy's
ass although that absolutely annihilate
him about all of that he's wearing to
make women great again huh
and he's just everything that's wrong
with like the whole sort of mono sphere
was too easy of a target of course you
could make fun of this idiot yeah he's I
think he's like the Kolby Covington UFC
fighter of like and I'm like this isn't
WWE you're supposed to be putting
yourself across as a legitimate man
development male development place I
mean if you're gonna play the heel the
bad guy at least do a good job like
Conor McGregor does a good job of that
right like there's a there's a way to do
that when you can do a good job they're
just it's they're too dumb or too
emotionally undeveloped to actually do
it well no like I'm gonna get a I'm
gonna get Rollo Tomassi on a really
really one of a discussion with Rollo I
want to find out who's guy that wrote
the rational male so he's widely
earmarked is the person who began the
red pill movement for men it seems like
he's Genesis for that or at least that's
why it's that's what it's called online
um I got a few I got a few questions for
that which today's helped to in in my
experience those dudes are extra all of
them are extraordinarily broken and they
just blame their [ __ ] on everyone else
even the ones no there's ones that make
really good arguments about a lot of
things right and so it's not like
because they're broken all their
arguments are wrong that's [ __ ] like
you can like you can all so many good
points about a lot of stuff and and it's
not like the other side it's not like
the [ __ ] social justice warrior is
really better they're just as awful
they're just as broken they're just as
victim mines that are worse but like
those dudes like it's like they get that
little I got any of them maybe they
little echo chamber it's like it's not
your phone so your fault either okay
will be broken and lonely together it's
like all right dude then go have your
shitty life it's all me look at the way
that what we spoke about twice two
different situations that have come up
in this conversation the first one is
how you find that nuance and that
understanding in yourself right doing
the work on yourself your truthfulness
and stuff like that and that not
actually being quite as polarizing and
some people not really even responding
to that as much you know you were the
party guy you were the dis guy you were
there that guy and then the second thing
being the book the book which delivered
a more nuanced more a deeper more
truthful more transparent more difficult
to swallow a pill and both of those
things kinda jar the jar with people
sometimes but they're easy to easy to
sort of swallow single line single tweet
length synopsis is more effective man I
wish it wasn't the case look at we're
gonna we're gonna talk about the scribe
method and everything else but you guys
launched David Goggins book if there's
people that are listening who want to
learn how to write a book 500 pages is
that the sky method PDA yeah just so we
have like look if you want something you
want to pay someone to do it all for you
or the company but most you the people
I'm sure can't just go to scribe books
cool calm everything that we do with our
clients who pay us five and six figures
to work with them we
all of it and lay it all out in detail
so if you don't if you don't have money
but you have time just it's all there
for free go do it yourself no problem
and you said this beautiful quote which
I've heard from you which says everybody
has wisdom inside of them they just need
to get it down onto a page something
along those lines
you have to get it out you can use video
to the wrong videos great man we're
about to launch a big YouTube channel
like but you need we just do books books
are a big way a really specific way um
they're not the only way and you got
specialists you're specialists in that
right that's your your background
awesome man took her if people wanna
hassle you online where should they go
Twitter LinkedIn Facebook I'm like I'm
not hard to find
glorious thanks man
[Music]
you